[Music]
if you're a raiders fan that decided to
make the bold but respectable decision
to fly out to miami for a pre-season
game how else do i put this
yikes the following players did not make
the trip to south beach derek carr
devonte adams max crosby hunter renfro
chandler jones and colton miller but
who's in the mood for a good cover band
jared stidham playing the role of hall
nick mullins
he could be oats as we know end result
less important but more so how it looked
well o-line had some rough moments the
eight sacks allowed in the two games
coming in four more here 12 total this
pre-season math is fun but not here alex
leatherwood started at right tackle and
felt the heat in this one but the
raiders did rush for 144 in the game as
for the most encouraging sign
as we know no crosby no jones but a
great play by linebacker darion butler
vegas held the dolphins just 37 yards on
the ground themselves they win it 15-13
here's mcdaniels and why those guys
didn't make the trip
each situation is really unique to its
own you know whoever the player is you
know we have like i said there's many
guys here that are
you know
rehabbing things and trying to shore up
some things that you know aren't
necessarily feeling perfect there's a
lot of things that go into trying to do
the right thing for the team that's all
we were trying to do but
the focus really should be on the guys
that came here really